dis-moi où sont les grignons 10 secondes
tu es mort intéressant je suis le seul à
savoir où est cette arme
nucléaire alors dans ce cas je dirais que tu ferais
mieux d'arrêter pourquoi tu as fait ça je ne l'ai pas
fait  exprès, c'est comme une tonne de
pollen ici mais j'ai arrêté d'enseigner et j'ai
rejoint la CIA Je pensais que ça allait être
cet espion incroyable et je suis juste la même
personne ennuyeuse que j'étais tu joues trop prudemment
J'entends juste la voix de ma mère juste  se fondre dans
laisser quelqu'un d'autre gagner faire une vague
n'est pas toujours courageux car alors abandonner
son rêve Susan juste pour écrire que dans
ma boîte à lunch nous avons intercepté des bavardages
que rayna boyanov sait où se trouve cette arme nucléaire
elle connaît l'identité de tous nos agents
nous avons besoin de quelqu'un pour trouver la bombe sans
être détecté mais ça ne peut pas être l'un d'entre
vous besoin de quelqu'un d'invisible je vais le faire d'
accord merci dame de midi je suis sérieux ne
me laisse pas tomber Cooper je ne vais pas je vais
te laisser tomber  arrête de parler je vais te laisser tomber
on te donne une nouvelle identité tu
ne seras plus Susan Cooper tu es pe  nny
Morgan, femme au foyer divorcée de l'Iowa, c'est
un constructeur de confiance,
vous pensez vraiment que vous êtes prêt pour le
terrain à la goélette, ce qu'il
vous prépare